!
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> Judge Jeanine: I CAN'T
HEAR!
>> Dana: WE ARE ALIVE AGAIN
FROM HOLLYWOOD, FLORIDA, FOR
THIS YEAR'S PATRIOT AWARDS, AND
ANOTHER AMAZING CROWD TONIGHT,
GIVE YOURSELVES A HAND!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND WE HOPE EVERYONE IS HAVING A
LOT OF FUN, WE HAVE A GREAT SHOW
COMING YOUR WAY STARTING WITH
SOME BIG NEWS ABOUT
NANCY PELOSI.
THE TOP DEMOCRATS CALLING IT
QUITS AFTER THEY TOOK BACK HER
GAVEL AFTER WINNING BACK THE
HOUSE.
>> WE MUST MOVE BOLDLY INTO THE
FUTURE, I WILL NOT SEEK
REELECTION TO DEMOCRATIC
LEADERSHIP IN THE NEXT CONGRESS.
FOR MAYBE OUR NEW GENERATION TO
LEAD THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS THAT
I SO DEEPLY RESPECT.
>> Dana: NANCY PELOSI IS
MERELY A 20 YEAR GRIP ON THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS FINALLY
COME TO AN END.
SHE WILL STAY AS A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS FROM THE NEXT TWO
YEARS, NO WORD WHAT IS BEYOND
THAT.
NANCY PELOSI STEPPING ASIDE
BECAUSE THERE IS A NEW SHERIFF
IN TOWN, REPUBLICANS WINNING
THAT MAGICAL NUMBER OF 218 HOUSE
SEATS WITH THE POSSIBILITY OF
THE MAJORITY WITH THE FURTHER
RACE STILL TOO CLOSE TO CALL, ON
TRACK TO BE THE NEXT SPEAKER IS
READY TO HOLD PRESIDENT BIDEN
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> IT IS ONE SIZE GAVEL WITH THE
ABILITY TO SUBPOENA AND HOLD
THIS GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE,
SECURE THIS BORDER, FIGHT TO
MAKE US ENERGY INDEPENDENT, GIVE
THE PARENTS A SAY IN THEIR KIDS
EDUCATION AND ACTUALLY LOOK WITH
THE DOJ IS DOING AND WHAT THE DH
S IS DOING, AND WHAT WE DO ON
DAY 1 IN THIS HOUSE.
>> Dana: JUDGE JEANINE,
NANCY PELOSI MAKING THAT
DECISION.
KIND OF INTERESTING SHE IS NOT
LEAVING CONGRESS, JUST SPEAKING
DOWN -- STEPPING DOWN FROM THE
SPEAKERSHIP AND HELPING HER
CONSTITUENTS.
>> Judge Jeanine: IT WAS
INTERESTING SHE TALKED ABOUT THE
NEW GENERATION, BUT I CAN'T
IMAGINE NANCY PELOSI ACTUALLY
STAYING IN CONGRESS AND NOT
HAVING -- IN THE HOUSE NOT
HAVING THE LEADERSHIP ROLE, I
JUST DON'T HAVE ANY INFORMATION
TO SUPPORT THAT.
BUT YOU KNOW, WE TAKE HER AT HER
WORD PURGE SHE WILL STAY THERE
AND COULD KEEP WORKING, NOT AT A
LEADERSHIP POSITION.
BUT WHAT IS GOING TO GET TO
THERE IS WHEN THE REPUBLICANS
START THE INVESTIGATIONS THAT
THEY PROMISED DURING THE
MIDTERMS AND THAT IS GOING TO
MAKE HER CRAZY, BECAUSE SHE
WANTED THE POWER THAT SHE HAD AS
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
AND I THINK THAT WHEN THEY START
THOSE INVESTIGATIONS, THEY
SHOULD RECOGNIZE THAT WHAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW IS
THE THINGS IN AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT AND THAT IS
THE COUNTRY GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION, THE COST OF FOOD
PRICES AND GAS PRICES.
BUT I THINK THERE IS ANOTHER
PIECE THAT HAS TO BE LOOKED
INTO, AND THAT IS THE ISSUE OF
HUNTER BIDEN, ALL OF THE MONEY
THAT HE HAS COLLECTED FROM
AROUND THE WORLD, AND WHAT
JOE BIDEN'S ROLE MAY HAVE BEEN
IN THAT SITUATION.
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS GOING
TO PUT HER OVER THE EDGE.
WE WILL SEE IT.
>> Dana: A COUPLE OF MEMBERS A
PRESS CONFERENCE EARLIER, AND
THEY TALKED ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATIONS, LET'S HEAR A
LITTLE BIT OF THAT.
I >> THIS IS AN INVESTIGATION
INTO JOE BIDEN, THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND WHY HE
LIED ABOUT HIS PARTICIPATION IN
HIS FAMILY AS INTERNATIONAL
BUSINESS GAMES PEER DOCUMENTS
SHOW THAT HE WAS A PARTNER WITH
ACCESS TO AN OFFICE TO BE CLEAR,
JOE BIDEN IS THE BIG DOG.
>> WE WENT FROM IT WAS NOT HIS
LAPTOP AND WAS RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION TWO OH, WHATEVER
WAS IN THERE DID NOT AFFECT THE
PRESIDENT'S BUSINESS DEALINGS
EVEN THOUGH HE WAS INVOLVED IN
THE LAPTOP WAS REAL EVEN THOUGH
IT WAS NOT JUST INFORMATION,
THAT'S HOW FAR WE HAVE COME.
>> Dana: RA, JESSE, SURE THAT
YOU WILL FOLLOW THAT ON
"PRIME TIME" BUT THERE WERE
PROMISES MADE BY HOUSE
REPUBLICANS WHEN THEY WERE
RUNNING FOR THE CONGRESS AND
THEY GOT THE MAJORITY, THEY
WOULD HAVE THE HEARINGS, SO HERE
WE GO.
>> Jesse: WE LEARNED A LOT IN
THE LAST 24 HOURS, ONE OF THE
THINGS IS HAROLD FORD JR. CAN
PARTY!
OH, MY GOD!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: YES!
>> Jesse: HOW MANY FINGERS AM
I HOLDING UP, HAROLD?
IF YOU ARE GOING TO A RUN FOR
PRESIDENT COMING YOU HAVE TO GET
THAT OUT OF YOUR SYSTEM.
>> Harold: YOU GOT HOME AFTER
I DID.
>> Jesse: I DID.
[LAUGHS]
SO THEY HAVE WITNESS TESTIMONY
AND BANK RECORDS AND THEY HAVE
THE LAPTOP, AND IT IS PROBABLY
GOING TO SHOW THAT JOE BIDEN
COMMITTED CONSPIRACY, WIRE
FRAUD, THERE WAS INVOLVEMENT IN
INTERNATIONAL SEX TRAFFICKING
THROUGH HUNTER BIDEN, AND
POSSIBLE ABUSE OF POWER AND
POSSIBLE IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES.
HE IS A THREAT TO NATIONAL
SECURITY.
HE HAS POSSIBLY COMPROMISED BY
AMERICA'S ENEMIES, BECAUSE HE
WAS LOOKING TO SELL OUT AMERICAN
GAS, DRILLING RIGHTS, COBALT TO
THE CHINESE CAMINO, HUNTER WAS
GETTING BRIBED BY DIAMONDS,
COMINGLING BANK ACCOUNTS, THEY
HAD SHELL COMPANIES SET UP
EVERYWHERE, 50 OTHER COUNTRIES
WERE INVOLVED IN THIS.
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY, THEY
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BRING IN
PEOPLE TO TESTIFY AND YOU CAN'T
KEEP A LID ON THIS FOR THAT MUCH
LONGER, BECAUSE THERE IS
SUSPICIOUS WIRE ACTIVITY COMING
IN FROM BEIJING AND MOSCOW, VERY
SUSPICIOUS THAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO BLOCK ACCESS TO.
SO WHEN THEY THROW THESE
SUBPOENAS DOWN, IT'S GOING TO
LOOK LIKE A COVER-UP, AND I AM
REALLY PROUD OF THE REPUBLICANS
FOR THROWING DOWN THE GAUNTLET
THAT HARD.
NOW I DON'T CARE IF IT IS A RED
WAVE, READ TRICKLE, NANCY PELOSI
IS GONE!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND VERY HAPPY ABOUT THAT, AND
SHE LEAVES ARE REALLY JUST A
VICIOUS LEGACY FROM CORRUPTION
TO OBAMACARE TO ALL KINDS OF
SHENANIGANS AND RECKLESS
SPENDING, AND THEY'RE GOING TO
PUT A BRAKE ON THE RECKLESS
SPENDING AND PUT IT OUT IN
FRONT, AND THE FIRST THING WE
WILL SEE AS I WANT TO SEE HIM
HOLDING IT SQUIRM, AND SEE HIM
DISCLOSE THOUGH ROYALTY IS HE IS
TAKING FROM BIG PHARMA, AND THEN
ALSO SEE THIS LITTLE MINI MEGA
DONOR TESTIFY WITH THE SENATE.
AND GETTING TO THE BORDER
SECURITY, AND AGAIN, JUST SLAM
THE BRAKES ON JOE BIDEN'S
AGENDA.
>> Dana: BORDER SECURITY,
GREG, SOMETHING THAT DOES AFFECT
EVERYONE, NOT JUST THE BORDER
STATES.
>> Greg: AT A MINIMUM WE WANT
TO RETURN TO NORMALCY, JUST HAVE
A NORMAL BORDER, MAY BE STOP
PEOPLE FROM STEALING SO MUCH,
THAT WOULD BE KIND OF NICE.
MAYBE MEN WHO THINK THEY ARE
WOMEN SHOULD NOT BE IN WOMEN'S
SPORTS, THESE ARE JUST SMALL
THINGS SO THAT WE WANT TO.
I'M GOING TO MISS NANCY PELOSI
AND HER UNIQUE EYEBROWS, WHICH
SEEMED PLUCKED FROM A DYING
PRAYING MANTIS.
BUT I DON'T THINK YOU ARE GOING
TO SEE IT GO AWAY.
I THINK THAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
HER GO FROM THE GAVEL TO THE
GAVIGAN.
RIGHT?
ARE THEY RELATED?
THEY SHOULD BE RELATED.
AND WE WILL COME THROUGH THE
FEMALE SCROOGE, RIGHT?
SHE WOULD BE PERFECT.
I AM ALL FOR THE STUFF WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOREVER, BUT
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT SOMETHING
ELSE AND BRING BACK THE MEMORIES
OF THE EARLY "THE FIVE."
WHEN THERE IS GRIDLOCK AND
BUDGETS, AT SOME OF THE MOST
BORING STUFF IN THE WORLD, BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT, AND GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWNS, DO YOU REMEMBER HOW
EVERY CONVERSATION ABOUT
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN WAS THE END
OF THE WORLD?
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT IN ONE
NATIONAL PARK CLOSED, WE WERE
ALL GOING TO DIE?
AND NOW THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
SAYING THAT WERE BEHIND THE
BIGGEST SHUTDOWN OF ALL TIME,
COVID.
IT DID NOT BOTHER THEM AT ALL.
AND I WENT INTO REMEMBER THAT
WHEN THE FIGHT COMES OVER
FUNDING.
FUNDING IS BORING, BUT THE FIVE
WILL COME AND WHEN WE START
CUTTING FUNDING THEY WILL SAY
THAT TO THE COUNTRY WILL DIE,
GRANNY WILL DIE, EVERYTHING WILL
DIE, BUT THEY PROVED US WRONG
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO, WHATEVER,
A FEW MONTHS AGO WHEN THEY SHUT
DOWN THE COUNTRY.
THERE WERE TOTALLY FINE WITH
THAT, STILL HERE, SO I THINK
THAT THAT WILL BE BALONEY, BUT I
WOULD DEFINITELY LIKE TO SEE ALL
OF THE THINGS THAT THE DEMOCRATS
TOOK FROM US BORING HAROLD, AND
IT'S GOOD TO SEE THAT YOU ARE
UP.
[LAUGHTER]
I SMOOTHED IT OVER WITH THE
FLORIDA POLICE.
I SAID, I SAID TO IT THAT YOU'VE
THOUGHT A NUDE BEACH.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: I GUESS THE JUDGE AND
I REALLY MISSED OUT LAST NIGHT.
>> Greg: THEY TOOK LAW AND
ORDER, SAFETY SECURITY, ACTUAL
THINGS, THEY TOOK OUR MONEY.
AND SO THE DEBATE AT THE MOST
BASIC LEVEL WHAT YOU WANT FROM A
REPUBLICAN HEALTH CONGRESS IS
JUST TO RETURN SOME OF THE STUFF
TAKEN AWAY.
AND GRIDLOCK IS BORING, BUT IT
IS IMPORTANT.
>> Dana: IT CAN BE GOOD.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO DEFEND
YOURSELF AND ALSO TALK ABOUT
NANCY PELOSI?
>> Harold: I'VE NO IDEA WHAT
THESE GUYS ARE TALKING ABOUT!
BEFORE IT'S NATURAL THAT YOU
WOULD NOT REMEMBER IT!
>> Harold: SO NANCY PELOSI, I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A
DESIRE, AND EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT
TO WANT TO REPUBLICANS IN
CHARGE, BUT WHEN DEREK JETER
RETIRED FROM BASEBALL, THE
RED SOX CLAP FOR HIM, SHE WAS A
FORMIDABLE FOE FOR REPUBLICANS,
SHE WAS EVEN FORMIDABLE FOR FOR
SOME DEMOCRATS, I RAN AGAINST
HER TO BE THE MINORITY LEADER OF
THE CONGRESS BACK IN 2002, SHE
HAS PROVEN TO BE AN
EXTRAORDINARY LEADER WHETHER YOU
AGREE WITH HER OR NOT, THE ONLY
SPEAKER THAT WON THE
SPEAKERSHIP, LOST IT, WON AGAIN,
LOST IT IN JUST 16 YEARS, SO I
CONGRATULATE HER.
A BRIDGE TO WHERE DEMOCRATS ARE
AND PROBABLY GOING, AND I
CONGRATULATE HER FOR OPENING THE
DOORS FOR A NEW GENERATION OF
LEADERSHIP TO BE USHERED INTO
CONGRESS.
TWO, AND ALL OF THE POLLING DATA
I SAW ABOUT WHY PEOPLE SHOULD GO
AND VOTE FOR REPUBLICANS OVER
DEMOCRATS THIS LAST ELECTION, I
DON'T RECALL ANY OF THE TOP TEN
BEING AN INVESTIGATION OF HUNTER
BIDEN, AN INVESTIGATION OF
DR. FAUCI OR SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT.
THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO DO THAT
AND I DO HOPE THAT WE HAVE AN
EQUAL EMPHASIS IF NOT MORE OF AN
EMPHASIS ON LEGISLATING THAN WE
DO INVESTIGATING.
>> Jesse: YOU DON'T GET TO SAY
THAT AFTER THE RUSSIA HOAX,
HAROLD.
NOBODY VOTED FOR THAT
INVESTIGATION.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Harold: BUT AT SOME POINT,
THE PAYBACK ON TOP OF PAYBACK ON
TOP A PAYBACK ON TOP OF PAYBACK
HAS TO STOP.
THIS IS NOT THIRD GRADE.
>> Jesse: YOU SAY THAT YOU
PUNCHED ME IN THE MOUTH, LET'S
NOT FIGHT ANYMORE?
>> Harold: BECAUSE PEOPLE
EXPECT PEOPLE IN POLITICS TO
LEAD, AND THEY WANT THE POLICE
PRACTICES AROUND THE COUNTRY SO
WE CAN EMPLOY IN CHICAGO AND
NEW YORK AND LOS ANGELES THEY
WANT TO HAVE A HEARING ON
EDUCATION TO HELP PARENTS ARE
INVOLVED AND THE MODEL WAVE FOR
THEM TO BE INVOLVED IN THE
COUNTRY SO WE CAN DO IT IN
MEMPHIS, BIRMINGHAM, MIAMI,
DALLAS, IF YOU WANT TO HAVE THE
HEARING ON BORDER SECURITY AND
HOW WE SHOULD BUILD THE WALL,
PUT MORE JUDGES DOWN THERE, SO
WE CAN FIGURE OUT WHO DESERVES A
SALOMON WHO DOESN'T AND FOR THAT
MATTER BRINGING A NEW WORKERS
THAT CAN HELP OUR COUNTRY, THOSE
ARE THE HEARINGS THAT I WANT
THEM TO HAVE.
IF THEY WANT TO INVESTIGATE
HUNTER AND JOE BIDEN --
>> Jesse: WANT TO HEAR WHETHER
PRESIDENT BIDEN SOLD THE COUNTRY
OUT TO THE CHINESE!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Harold: SO ASK HIM, MY ONLY
POINT IS THIS, IF THAT'S WHERE
THE FOCUS IS OF THE NEXT TWO
YEARS, THERE WILL BE A
DEMOCRATIC SPEAKER.
>> Jesse: WE CAN WALK AND CHEW
GUM AT THE SAME TIME.
>> Harold: AND SPIT.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHO WAS
COLLUDING WITH THE RUSSIANS LAST
NIGHT?
HAROLD.
HE HAD LIKE SEVEN WHITE
RUSSIANS.
>> Harol